larg scale protests have been growing
across the United States with the
demonstrators demanding a ceasefire
they're also calling for the government
to stop sending arms to Israel and to
put more pressure on Benjamin Netanyahu
to stop the bombardment of civilians
we're joined Now by Sahar Hamish
professor of communication at University
of Maryland and she's joining us by
Skype from Washington DC thank you very
much for your time is the US president
out of step with what American want a
new data for Progress poll shows that
80% of Democrats 56% of Republicans and
57% of Independence believe the US
should call for a
ceasefire thank you so much for having
me there is definitely a growing
sentiment here in the United States and
also around the world to really save the
lives of innocent civilians in Gaza
especially the children who are being
killed day in and day out the elderly
women mothers shouting and screaming and
yelling as as their kids are being
killed in front of their own eyes these
pictures are now circulating around the
world and social media is carrying them
everywhere and people can see these
atrocities day in and day out so really
there's a growing uh public opinion
pressure here in the United States
unfortunately the Biden Administration
up until this moment did not seem to
really respond in a way which is firm
decisive strong or satisfactory to meet
these demands you know the calls for
quote unquote humanitarian pauses or
techical pauses whatever it may be does
not rise to the level of responsibility
which is needed which is basically
calling for an immediate ceasefire that
did not happen yet well the Biden uh
President Biden did say a few days ago
when he announced when the US government
announce what they're calling
humanitarian pauses these
4our pauses in fighting in Israeli
attacks he said that he asked prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu for a
ceasefire and that the Israeli
government wouldn't agree to one is that
good enough given how many billions of
dollars the US government gives Israel
how much leverage it has with its
Ally exactly exactly you hit the point
very well I mean the United States does
have leverage over Israel it is the
greatest supporter of the Israeli Army
and a lot of our taxpaying money you
know our taxpaying dollars goes to
supporting uh you know a country which
is now bombing and killing uh you know
fellow Muslims and Arabs in in Gaza
which is completely unacceptable for a
very large segment of the Arab slm
Muslim population not just in the United
States but also around the world so when
the US says well you know he is not
listening he's not responding he doesn't
really like the idea of the ceasefire he
wants all the hostages to be released
first this language does not you know
really fly well with a lot of people
they don't take it because they're like
is it that the US cannot put pressure or
it does not want to put pressure you
know what I'm saying like is it about
the ability to put pressure or about the
decision not to put pressure so there is
really this kind of Leverage which is
not being used effectively or
productively to put an end to all
hostilities now and to save thousands of
more lives especially of innocent
civilians and children and if it is that
the US administration of President Joe
Biden if it's that they do not want to
put pressure why is
that I think that there has been an
adopted line by the Biden Administration
from day one since the beginning of OA
flood events on October 7th which is
basically support for Israel which
seemed in many cases one-sided very much
just pro-israel all the way through in a
way that did not please a lot of the
Democrats a lot of the uh even the
supporters of Biden who said like you
know wait a minute what is this kind of
policy why are you being so one-sided to
that extent and of course there were
some pro- Israelis who really like that
and they're cheering him up up till this
moment but it seems to me like there is
some kind of support for the Israeli
Ally in this particular case at the
expense of Human Rights and
international law and there are now
certain voices that say wait a minute if
the US continues this course of action
it's very likely going to lose a very
big part of its own International
Leadership and credibility and allies in
the Middle East region as well as around
the world so there's going to be
definitely a big cost for this kind of
US policy and it might be also a case of
isolation for the United States and
Israel and few Western allies on one
hand and the rest of the world on the
other hand and we know that there is
pressure on the Biden Administration to
change CES from Arab and Muslim allies
we but what about um the latest
statements from the French President
Emanuel macron who said that there is no
legality no justification for killing
civilians in Gaza just how much of a
shift is that could hearing that from
his French Ally from his Western Ally
influence Joe Biden do you
think I'm glad that you raised this
point because just a moment ago I was
saying saying it's going to be isolation
for the US and Israel and Western allies
you know facing the rest of the world
now it seems that this Camp of Western
allies is also starting to be fragmented
there is some kind of cessation from
this particular Camp so when you see
Emanuel macron using this language and
saying oh stopping all hostilities now
and these are war crimes and this is not
acceptable this is not legitimate
definitely that sends a message and it
sends an alarm Bell to the Biden
Administration hey it's not just about
International public op opinion it's not
just about people protesting in the
streets it's not just about Arab SL
Muslim nations even some of your own
Western allies are starting to really
stray away from this kind of policy and
to say Hey you really need to adopt a
much stronger clearer more firm and more
humanitarian policy now miss kames it is
great to get your expertise on the story
we really appreciate it that is Sahar
kamam joining us live from Washington
DC thank you so much